hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute ja meine damen und
herren richtig gesehen zu einem neuen
video von mir hier seht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet ihr seht es bereits
auch schon hier eingeblendet wie spielen
heute nämlich clash royal ein spiel das
es schon lange gibt ich aber trotzdem
immer noch spiele bevor wir uns
allerdings in das spielgeschehen stürzen
meine lieben freunde habe ich noch eine
ganz kurze sache zu sagen und zwar jetzt
schon oben werden video eingeblendet und
zwar ist das hier gerade eine
kooperation mit dem sonnemondsterne
festival falls ihr das sonnemondsterne
festival by the way nicht kennen sollte
seht ihr jemand das leihen aber
eingeblendet also dass eine kraft die
jazz am start wie beispielsweise david
guetta hardware marshmallows die für
europa felix oliver held und noch viele
viele weitere jeder von euch der mir bei
instagram volk weiß dass ich vor einigen
tagen dieses bild hier bereits
hochgeladen habe worunter ihr auch für
das festival tickets für ein meet and
greet mit mehr gewinnen konnte
da die nachfrage allerdings so groß war
haben wir uns jetzt gedacht okay wir
machen das ganze nochmal hierbei
sonderschau dort unseren kleines extra
ding für das festival und zwar verlose
ich 40 ticket zu einem exklusiven
partyboot meet and greet mit regie und
mir alles was ihr dafür tun müsst um
region milch quasi zu treffen und diese
eine stunde mit dem partyboot herum zu
fahren und wir können uns unterhalten
und so weiter und so fort es mit mega
cool aber alles was ihr dafür tun müsst
ist quasi ihr euch entweder ein ticket
kaufen für das festival oder ihr habt
den besten fall halt schon 1 und dann
findet ihr jetzt uns in der video
beschreibung einen link eingeblendet und
wenn ihr da drauf klickt könnt ihr dort
eure ticketnummer eure e-mail-adresse
und luca auswählen wenn ihr das gemacht
habt habt ihr die chance einen von 40
plätzen mit auf diesem boot zu gewinnen
den ich an euch verlosen werde also wenn
ihr mich treffen wollte und rege treffen
wollte auf einem exklusiven party bot
beim sonnemondsterne festival da macht
das gern und ich würde mich mehr freuen
wir uns dass sehen wären und jetzt gehts
los mit dem gameplay also das hier ist
klärt royal
das hier ist mein klar da kann ich mir
eben kurz ein paar sachen hier spenden
ich glaube die meisten leute werden kate
royal kennen hier vorne rechts sein wie
die cr liegt darum werden wir uns heute
allerdings nicht kümmern einem dass sie
ist quasi der standard screen kämpfen
das hier ist mein weg so sieht das aus
aber ich kann mir eine hexe verbessern
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir machen einfach
learning by doing
ich habe mir erst mal noch jemand ruhe
habe also in so tun die kriegt man wenn
man viel gewinnen wenn man quests lösen
und so
dort kommt man dann an neue karten und
an gold mit dem man dann sein weg
verbessern kann so sieht das ganze jetzt
hier aus aber ich bekomme jetzt hier
unten vier karten auf meinem weg
ausgewählt und kann jetzt erstmal
rumheulen weil das immer gut zu beginnen
jetzt hätte ich mal einfach hier unten
eine hexe hin weil ihr seht schon alex
ihr geht voll und davon muss sich quasi
die karten bezahlen mit denen ich jetzt
kämpfen möchte online ich habe die
anderen lok hat lakaien noch drin es ist
natürlich geschmackssache wer mit
welchen deck kämpfte mich meine ich
könnte jetzt auch noch ein schwein
reiter mit dazu nehmen oder keine ahnung
was aber ich kann zum beispiel ganz gut
mit diesem deckel kämpfen er hat jetzt
hier in drachen und eine hexe links
eingesetzt das heißt ich könnte mir
jetzt einfach mal eine walküre ich finde
eigentlich nichts am besten so wenn es
gegen die hexe geht oder so jetzt habe
ich natürlich keine lakaien mit denen
ich den drachen hätte töten können
allerdings hat das maintower hier und
erledigt einem das ziel des spiels ist
es diesen königs turm da hinten zu
zerstören ich gönne mir jetzt mal hier
vorne den prinzen weil er halt vorhin
schon seine skelett armee eingesetzt hat
und der die skelette mir ist eigentlich
das krasseste wenn es gegen den prinzen
geht oh mein gott freunde
das könnte von 1
zu den prinzen zerstört und hier vorne
ist jetzt der erste turm zerstört das
heißt jetzt kann ich quasi auf den
königsthron draufgehen ihr vorne ist
gerade von meinem prinzessinnen tor ich
weiß nicht ob es wirklich prinzessin den
turm heißt aber er ist auf jeden fall
raten menge los freunde mit papier grad
ein bisschen angst weil die alle relativ
kratz dollar
hier vorne rechts ist klettern damit der
prinz dann natürlich nicht vorankommt
wenn es übrigens unentschieden steht
dann also jetzt gerade steht sie
unentschieden gibt es eine verlängerung
von irgendwie 60 sekunden bis er wäre ja
zuerst quasi daran herum zerstört hat
und das werde ich jetzt ich sein denn
hier vorne oder so jetzt hat man den
könig zum zerstört und haben das spiel
jetzt quasi gewonnen erst mal hier zu
beginn natürlich ein bisschen rum
flennen jetzt habe ich mal hier vorne
den ballon hin und supportet den aber
auch mit den lack ein der nach vorne den
hass sicher total der fried die teile 1
damit die hat langsam attackieren und
soja kommen ja noch eine zweite lakaien
horden kommt eine fette rakete hier hin
dass die alle als wenn ihr nicht
verrückt sind okay ich bin wieder ganz
schon am arsch gerade diese erste
angriffswelle ist halt echt mal am
wichtigsten das hat er gerade halt
relativ gut gemacht
hier vorne befindet sich jetzt gerade so
ein komischer skelett riesig findet er
bringt 0
ich finde ihn so kacke lotus mit der
bombe ist natürlich gut hier eine
walküre gegen die ganze skelette damit
die auf jeden fall erstmal wechselnder
teils hat meinen ritter natürlich null
komma null gebracht jetzt komme ich hier
halt von zwei seiten er hat jetzt auf
der linken seite den skelette riesen
hier vorne am start der kommt aber
relativ nicht so gut an gegen die hexe
und kommt mit einer bombe noch dieser
eine bombe noch das okay wenigstens den
haben wir leute ich bin gerade
eigentlich relativ gut drin
märz vorne die skelette mir eingesetzt
das heißt er sollte jetzt eigentlich
keine zweite am außenspiegel ein spiegel
deshalb krass weil man dann die gleiche
karte die man folgen gesetzt hat nochmal
setzen kann ich bin gerade auf jeden
fall strasser als er im angriff ich
hoffe jetzt nur dass der ballon dass da
hinten gegen die regeln wird online
alter genau in dem moment den
wirbelsturm oder was ja das ganze geht
jetzt noch zwei sekunden wird jetzt
keiner gewinnen das ist ein
unentschieden man ey ich hätte den safe
kriegen können
an der stelle würde ich jetzt allerdings
auf das heutige video beenden meine
damen und herren ich weiß ist royal
schon seit jahren auf dem markt ist
schon seit jahren im web vertreten ist
ich habe allerdings noch nie so wirklich
auf einem kanal hochgeladen
deswegen hab ich mal gedacht kommen
nächstes mal hoch ich spiele halt immer
mal ab und zu und ja wenn es euch
gefallen hat was lag da wie gesagt zu
beginnen ich habe alles gesagt was man
machen kann wenn ihr mich treffen wollte
und das wasser das war es jetzt hier vom
video hier können jetzt hier meinen
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job stecken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wendischen abonnenten zeit
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]